[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and we have some
breaking news this morning that the
upcoming Sony film Morbius will be
connected to the MCU this comes through
Tyrese Gibson who is set to star in the
film apparently telling Charlamagne tha
God that the movie will be connected to
the greater universe and it's a pretty
interesting reveal I'll play the
interview in just a second but if this
is the case and there's definitely a lot
to look forward to if this turns out to
be true
I'll leave the full link in the
description below so if you want to
watch the entire show then make sure you
click it after this without the way
Thank You Brooke in this video now let's
get into the clip so you got Morbius
next summer
Tyrese isn't that Teresa a giant Leto
and Tyrese actually told me um I was
speaking him couple weeks ago he
actually told me that they do in the
Morbius movie but then it's uh they all
have deals to do three other movies
really yeah so many and he did say to me
that it would all be in the MCU whoa so
we just got that exclusive right here
that's crazy
he did say that so he said that he's
gonna cross over into the MCU you think
he's lying or you think he's down the
truth heap or does he know you know
something that nobody else knows I don't
think he would have any reason to lie I
mean I don't know like I don't know Sony
Toni Sony's putting out more because
it's a spider-man character yeah
interesting
yeah but you did say that um they're
doing the Morbius movie and it's they're
gonna enter names to you but I mean all
that's gonna intertwine okay that's
blade that's what I'm saying that's why
I was like they need to make this deal
happen because yeah you could do a blade
you could do a blade versus more based
on the line even if Morbius isn't good I
would still love to see I'm rehearsal
Ali's blade versus Jared Leto is Morbius
I think that's a dope idea and that's a
great way to kind of bring the
spider-verse more into the MCU why would
even give him Morbius is staying a
little movie because they're just trying
to build up this villain verse you know
I'm saying like venom 2 supposed to come
out next year to Andy Serkis is
directing at the guy who played Ulysses
Claus in a black panther he's directing
in you know you have woody house and I'm
venom coming back
and I heard spider-man's gonna be
actually have a cameo in that movie
unlike the last venom I think what
they're doing I think they're they have
a plan and I think it's an okay plan but
now it's is kind of like alright so
y'all gonna be in the MCU or y'all gonna
keep it separate yeah okay so that seems
pretty interesting and honestly it seems
like a pre offical leak I'm pretty much
gonna take Charlemagne at his word on it
I guess this pretty much confirms that
the Sony verse which includes venom
Morbius and the upcoming Madame web
movie will be connected to the MCU and
that the two corporations will be slowly
merging their properties together I'm
obviously really excited about this
especially with the reveal that they are
all contracted to do three movies and I
think that this is the perfect way to
flesh out the MCU even more and truly
build a cinematic universe that has non
stuff releases for fans now how it will
be connected we are yet to know but if
there's an appearance by Tom Holland
before spider-man 3 the following year
then I think fans will hit the roof I
don't know if Tyrese or Charlemagne
should have told other people this but I
guess that's the rumor mill in full
effect
someone's gonna be in big big trouble
with Mickey Mouse anyway if they bring
blade into the franchise as it's
theorized in this video then I think
going forward the MCU has the potential
to be absolutely incredible now
obviously I'd love to you your thoughts
on this clip and what you think of it do
you want to see the Sony movies
connected to the MCU fully or do you
want them to be kept separate with Tom
Holland just jumping back and forth
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
up and use that and older general Ross
was seen on the set of Black Widow so we
can assume that part of the movie will
be served at endgame I cover the entire
story and give my theories on it so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to come chat
to me about movies TV shows games and
comic books then make sure you follow me
on twitter at definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this well so just
wanna let you know that we're currently
giving away a free copy of spider-man
far from home on blu-ray and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on Morbius
in the comment section below the winner
will be chosen at random on October the
15th and blue arrow be shipped out from
then to ever gets the prize it's the
best of luck to everyone he takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]